monsieur marraud des grottes est-ce que
vos enfants à vous irez travailler pour
le smig dans vos plantations
est-ce que vos enfants à vous lire et
travailler dans vos plantations pour le
ce mais ne comptez pas sur la filière
vont faire la publicité à ce monsieur
venu du froid qui s'adresse aux
martiniquais avec son gilet de costume
trois pièces
il n'a qu'un objectif de diviser la
profession et ça c'est criminel simpara
eh bien bon jour nous voici de retour
dans le dossier banane le dossier banane
petits producteurs de bananes puisque
évidemment c'est un secret pour personne
maintenant air et d'hommes soutien très
fortement les petits producteurs de
bananes des antilles qui sont
littéralement comme beaucoup d'entre eux
le 10 des exploités à l'école non pas
des exploitants agricoles les marges par
toujours toujours dans les mêmes poches
et les marges ne vont pas aux petits
producteurs qui peuvent effectivement
pardonnez moi ce mot un peu dur mais qui
crève les uns vers les autres
qu'ils crèvent de faim les uns vers les
autres ça c'est pas acceptable j'ai
encore un mot également un gémeaux pour
les grands planteurs de bananes un mot
pour monsieur à eau des grottes qui m'a
réservé son c'est quelqu'un que pitch
pas trop bien compris je vais lui dire
ceci monsieur moreau des gones les
salariés que vous payez vos salariés
vous touchez les grands producteurs vous
toucher des indemnités de des indemnités
de peau c'est y qui sont supérieures à
100 % des salaires et charges que vous
devez payer pour vos salariés
est ce que vous pensez réellement
monsieur marraud des grottes que avec le
smic
les ouvriers agricoles qui travaillent
dans vos plantations arrive à s'en
sortir
et bien moi je vous dis non monsieur
aujourd'hui dans vos plantations ses
plantations sont essentiellement pourvu
en main d'oeuvre par une main de
haïtienne et par une main 2,5 lucienne
et je salue nos amis de sainte lucie je
salue nos amis d'haïti mais eux ce sont
des populations qui peuvent - discuter
que d'autres et c'est pour ça parce
qu'ils ne sont plus vulnérables qu'elles
qu'on les retrouve dans les
exploitations et moi je vous dis ceci
avec l'argent que vous prenez au niveau
du procès qui courent je le redis plus
de 100% de vous savez ray charles
augmentez vos salaires moi je dis
augmenter vos salaires vous devriez
montez vos salaires de 30% il faudrait
monter ses salaires là pourquoi pour que
les gens puissent véritablement vivent
avec des salaires
monsieur marraud des grottes est-ce que
vos enfants à vous irez travailler pour
le smic dans vos plantations
est-ce que vos enfants à vous irez
travailler dans vos plantations pour le
semi
d'avancé merci pour votre futur réponse
on ne lâche rien on se bat dans la
banane à très bientôt